bex is the world's best-selling German
beer and it's one of the leading brands
in the portfolio of the world's biggest
Brewer on hyser Busch InBev or a be in
bed for short their brands include
Budweiser corona and stella artois and
many more the company has a global
market share by volume of over twenty
percent but that's not all a be in bev
and world number two sabmiller have
agreed to merge together they would
produce more than 700 million
hectoliters of beer a year and have
sales of more than 61 billion euros
their global market share is thirty-one
percent a B and Bev is headquartered in
Belgium it's German operations are based
at the Becks planned in Bremen Beck's
has been brewed here for decades now the
a be in bed flag flies here Beck's was
an independent company until 2002 when
it was sold does that upset loyal
customers does is absolutely absolutely
will change and huge companies make
people wary of course we tend to assume
that small outfits do things more
carefully and better why is a bee and
Bev willing to spend more than a hundred
billion euros to take over us-based
sabmiller and control that even more
confusing range of brands skip CLE
classes there will certainly be
classical synergy effects in purchasing
raw materials packaging and so on I
juanita for a fact that is not the
primary reason why such a merger makes
sense it makes perfect sense when you
look at all the brands the two firms
have and at the new marketing
opportunities and possible brand swaps
hunger w underlying aim is to provide
consumers with a wider range of products
144 honk or the salty min tun subpoena
the countries that consume the most beer
also produced the most China makes the
most beer followed by the United States
Brazil and Germany the German market is
unlike others endorsement yet in German
seventy percent of beer is sold in
stores and thirty percent is consumed in
pubs and restaurants that is unusual in
almost all markets it is the other way
round with most beer drunk when people
go out decline of the Taylor hundred
that insight into German drinking habits
may come as quite a surprise so if these
bottles stay in Germany more than likely
they will be enjoyed at home